if we look at the facts Miss salmon was
outside of court and spoken by myself
and and her solicitor Kelly Darlington
we spoke about we use me someone's words
she said you know we felt like we
weren't treated the same because we were
from a different country and what this
report has done is actually validated
exactly what they said there were people
actually and I saw these comments that
said why is race being brought into this
and this report shows that actually not
only is there evidence of othering by
Rochdale whitehousing but actually their
own staff have said that sometimes they
would raise things with managers at rbh
and they would see things along the
lines of well this mold you know the
family you're actually looking to even
have a house because they're refugees so
it's deeply upsetting and frankly deeply
worrying okay
so they thought that because this family
had a roof over their head that was
enough and it didn't matter whether
there was mold like on the image behind
you there well that's what the Ombudsman
report would seem to suggest and what
was particularly concerning when reading
that was just the fact that a web's case
was not in anomaly I received those
papers and I remember thinking wow I
can't believe things to this extent
happen and the fact that actually so
widely within rbh this this was taking
place potentially still is is worrying
and at the the inquest was in um
December of last year and at that point
eighty percent of properties owned by
rbh still had mold in them oh I've died
two years prior to that so it's it's
deeply upsetting it's what's the
situation with the family now
the family are still struggling of
course because of the the magnitude of
the loss however they are deeply worn by
The public's support
um Michael ghost now committed to an old
web's law which will set time limits
ensuring that
um landlords should fix issues of damp
and mold within certain time scales and
other issues so it's positive and
they've
um I had a phone call with them and
spoke to them about the key points of
this report and again they were warmed
by that so nothing will ever bring a web
back but them seeing that changes are
taking place gives them a bit of
confidence that no other family has to
go through that the pain that they have
and we're hearing from the leveling up
secretary he's saying no more money for
this organization and to build new
houses until they can prove that they've
they've improved on their on their
behavior when it comes to fixing
problems and also you know depending on
who they're talking to dealing with
people differently which is totally and
utterly unacceptable
um is that something that the family
support that no more money should be
given to organizations like this or do
they think more houses do need to be
built in order to try and get rid of
this sort of issue that's claimed the
life of the Sun in Truth for the family
that the politics is less of their
concern for them it's just that no other
family can be put in this situation and
they would say whatever needs to be done
to ensure that is is the steps that need
to take place but we have to appreciate
there's a a a precedence of not
particularly much trust towards rbh
because for example it was the fact that
you know we had to call for there to be
a change in the leadership that didn't
come naturally
um the fact that actually as the report
makes clear and perhaps one of the most
worrying parts of the report
um Rochdale broadhousing themselves did
a survey of all of their properties and
actually when the survey was then done
again in 2022 that uncovers so many more
instances of damp than rbh had spotted
themselves which begs the question well
actually can we really trust rbh to
properly get to the bottom of this okay
thought before I let you go what advice
would you give to people watching at
home this morning who might find
themselves in this position or know
somebody who is
well what what is the one positive out
of this is that there is a spotlight on
these issues now so I would encourage
you to contact your local MP I always
speak about quagio who's done brilliant
work in this area for a while getting in
touch with him going on social media it
seems that sadly public pressure is
often now the only way in which action
will be taken do that go on go on social
media talk about what's happening shout
loud yes okay it's good to see you